I'm thinking about trig functions at the
inverse trig functions and what happens
when you put them together so this is
trying to go back to two days ago okay I
do you remember we are we looked at for
instance side or after we did all the
graphs of like sine of sine inverse sine
inverse of sine cos inverse of M no no
no not right we look at what happened
when we mix the bar okay so we have a
look at something like this now Z don't
remember we now actually look at you in
your workbook they don't have n what
this is the - this is a semicircle right
it's um it's the top half of the unit
circle okay so you get this and
interestingly if you swap them around
and you took all this on a sine inverse
you got you actually get exactly the
same thing
okay yeah that's right okay now just
quickly eight now you can go back to
your book for this one help me help me
get these down what all the other ones
let's do the ten we had some fractions
yeah then this was two days ago
it's just two days ago so everyone
should be here I think have you gone
there
yes yeah now if I remember right this is
just the reciprocal right is that right
when you do customers yep that's what
minus X X and then the other two I think
we looked at were cause of cannabis
okay these are the equal reflections
here which one was which wait was it one
was it X okay one on route 1 plus okay
now this is helpful this is useful to us
okay but if you remember how do we
actually arrive at these results like
how did we come up with these ratios
what did we use yeah we used to triangle
right we drew it then we use Pythagoras
and so on okay now we've done that
before for something else earlier in the
year you remember what we did that for
we use their forty results right which
gave us like the right kinds of ratios
but we noted there was a problem with
doing that what was the problem that's
right it only works now it's not it's
not for X because X in this case is not
an angle right it's a ratio okay so if I
called sine inverse or cos inverse or
whatever if I call that theta okay it
only worked for the restriction not only
was it a triangle but it's a
right-angled triangle so that's why it's
got to be a cube okay
now that doesn't make these wall but it
means you do very careful okay in
particular you have to be careful about
the side okay so positive negative okay
is where these kinds of things start to
get a bit confusing okay and when you
actually put actual numbers in that's
what the headings about you will see
this express so let's do it a sip what
we do okay so okay yeah I'll start off
with a simple example without any tricks
or traps in it and then we'll progress
to the the more confusing ones okay now
how would you go about working this out
okay
remembering that cuz universe that's not
how you worked it out that's the answer
remember the Kazi Versova ratio that's
actually angle right so what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to say let that equal an
angle
Theatre okay now if I'm putting a
restriction on theater which I'll
explain later on why it's just the phone
okay I'm going to say close theta is
three on five okay remember you have to
be careful about this because cause
Elizabeth doesn't always equal just
three or five okay sometimes I'm going
to go with this one but here it's okay
right
so what triangle that get gonna get out
of this this is a 3 4 5 triangle isn't
it which anglers they are it's the top
one right because it's adjacent on
hypotenuse okay great so this is
actually based on the way I've rewritten
it this is just sine theta in this
triangle which is opposite over
hypotenuse no problems okay but when you
start to add in negative ratios okay it
starts to get confusing because this
triangle that I've just drawn everything
is positive right so if I put in a
different number let's go cause of so
this is example one which is super easy
it's good cause of tan inverse minus
what's that equal to okay now in order
to try to take into account the fact
that there's a negative here right so
something here is negative
probably just drawing a triangle and put
it out in the middle of space okay I'm
going to draw a quadrants diagram that's
the way we've usually been thinking
about trig ratios and where they're
positive and where they're negative
right so here's my question right now
the first thing I want to know and
you've please try it on get these steps
down because I've I know when I learned
this the first time it was confusing
hopefully I do enough our exams with you
don't you know settle into your mind but
there's lots of little tricks
the first thing you want to think about
is telling us okay now Tanny of us has a
range where does tan inverse go in
between because it can't just be any
angle right we restricted which poses a
restriction what was it that's right and
it wasn't inclusive right because you've
got the asymptotes okay so whatever this
angle is which I caught the corner
theater before right it's got to be
between minus PI to implant - right so I
automatically know it's in this quadrant
or this quadrant right there's my plan -
there's my - cartoon there and there
okay so these - I've already ruled out
okay now the second thing I noticed is
that is turning another negative ratio
okay so that means 10 should be negative
10 people should be negative right so
now out of these two quadrants which
ones which one do I choose right well it
can't be this one because 10 positive
here right so it must be down Tiana okay
so now I know I'm in the fourth quadrant
or in the negative one lady of first
quadrant
okay so now I'm actually going to draw
my triangle okay so famous is minus one
over three so and this is the kind of
the scales pretty terminal if I put
theta in there you know okay where did
the one in the three girth
it's opposite on adjacent right so this
is the minus one and this is the three
is that okay not to scale at all okay
but you get the idea right okay so now
that I have minus one there and three
there right what's the other side which
is what I need for cos what's the
hypotenuse should be
root n right root n yes what you got
there fellas
so yeah if I want to have cause of this
angle cos theta right I just say it's
adjacent on hypotenuse right Jason ah I
put news no is it going to be sorry so
Jason what happens to that ratio now is
a positive or negative and the answer is
I'm in this fourth quadrant right and
cause is positive in this quadrant okay
so it's positive I'm using the diagram
for the purpose of determining sign not
to determine the size of a was like okay
okay now just let me rehearse that again
okay because what I've always got
confused by was I don't think about okay
can you most it's it's negative right so
I I feel like I could be in this
quadrant or this quadrant 10 is negative
about these quadrants right but the
reason why I knew it couldn't be this
one do you remember why why could it be
this one it was yet the range
restriction means you know it only goes
from - miles - platitudes aplenty
okay now you see why that's critically
employment if I've gotten that wrong and
I chosen this quadrant okay and drawn
this triangle let's see there's theta so
I would say it's opposite adjacent so
you see how I've done it still - 103
okay but I would have got the final
answer wrong because I would have said
look I'm doing cause of this angle that
it causes negative in this quadrant okay
so my answer would be - really - which
is wrong okay so this is a little
confusing right but it should go through
these two steps right number one no
restriction number two think about okay
now I posted menu you'll get the right
quadrant now that's that's not very hard
for me that's not very comfy okay so
you've got a you've got a safety then
you've got a parachute okay cuz this guy
even if it's some weird number right it
can tell you whether something is
positive or negative
pretty easily right in fact if you've
got
the ratios get your calculator out No
okay and you'll be very disappointed to
find out
I didn't enjoy triangles are near that
rubbish because you can just go
literally sine of cos inverse of 3/5
close all your brackets and it just
gives you the exact no yeah why am I
wasting my time with this okay you know
even here where it's not it's not a nice
easy number like you go ahead and do it
what's the decimal value cause I'm tan
inverse of minus 1 3 so so this is
actually equal to 0.94 okay but what it
does tell you is that's clearly positive
right like even if you don't know what
that number is it's fine okay now you
probably think you what but you know I
can swear this if you square this what
will happen don't give you the fraction
out don't give you violent n so then you
take the square root you okay through
every 10 it's fine alright so we've used
that trick before so why am I going
through all this effort trying to teach
you how to pick the right quadrants and
the answer is later our particular when
I had expansions to this this method
just using a calculator it's not gonna
cut it okay if there's any house ever
involved this guy Continental or at
least a calculator which you're allowed
to breed to be example okay so I use the
calculator as a check right you need to
know how to work out where this is from
that's about demonstrate understanding
right but if you want sure like okay you
go to this and you double check if it
was this question I've been very
surprised it was any more than one lakh
right if we're something like this yeah
maybe one mark baby to in which case
they're expecting something there yeah
yeah well they're expecting you to
demonstrate why you understand it's one
quadrant or another okay so if you don't
have a diagram here you're gonna have to
make some statements you're gonna have
to explain because blah blah blah blah
because tan is name
and so on therefore I know I have this
restriction so well I think this
communicates that so but most people 95%
of people will just draw the diagram
because that's the easiest way to work
it out and then they'll use this to
check